getting Aid into Gaza immediately is
both vital and complicated there are
seven Crossings around the Gaza Strip
all are controlled by Israel except one
Rafa which connects Gaza and Egypt Egypt
controls that Crossing but Israel Bond
it on the 10th of October and again on
October the 16th since the War Began
there's been conflicted information
about when or if the crossing will open
and people have been waiting thousands
of tons of international aid for Gaza
have already been prepositioned at
Egypt's Aller airport 45 km from Gaza
and a convoy of trucks carrying
essential supplies is stalled near the
border Egypt has reinforced its side of
the Raffa Crossing with concrete walls
it doesn't want to repeat of 2008 when
thousands of people stormed the barrier
from the Gaza side the UN says it'll
only be able to distribute Aid when
there's a pause in the fighting but two
draft resolutions for humanitarian
ceasefire have failed to pass at the UN
security Council instead US President
Joe Biden broken a deal with Egypt to
open the crossing for Aid and he
extracted a promise from Israel not to
bomb it meanwhile the UN Secretary
General Antonio Gus is in Egypt where he
hopes personally to oversee the delivery
to Gaza the UN says its supplies include
food for a quarter of a million
Palestinians for a week medicine for
300,000 people and Trauma kits but
Biden's deal only allows 20 truckloads
into Gaza a fraction of what's need
before the war the UN said about a 100
trucks would deliver humanitarian Aid to
Gaza every single day and it's not clear
whether fuel will come from to deliver
these desperately needed items to all
corners of the Gaza
Strip